Iman when I say her name I have to go
Iman walked into the Fashion World just
19 years old she went on to make history
as the first black supermodel after
arriving in the U.S as a refugee she
booked her first modeling job with Vogue
and started walking runways worldwide
for the likes of Chanel Versace Donna
Karen heard of them yeah behind the
scenes Iman fought for equal pay and
representation for black models in 1988
she co-founded the black girls Coalition
with models Beth Ann Hardison who's her
best friend and Naomi Campbell we all
know Naomi too it serves as an advocacy
and support group for models of color
now she is an executive producer thank
you very much of a new six-part
documentary it's called Supreme models
it tells the stories of black models
shattering barriers and their impact on
fashion beauty standards here's a look
at the trailer
there is nothing like a black model
under
[Music]
says the black girls Coalition if it
wasn't for them we would have been
overlooked we can't move forward without
black creativity the new generation they
want a revolution how can you not love
this melanin
we're not going back to the old days
just one token model
how could you not love this melody hello
Yvonne it's so good to see you good to
see you too so you know I love when you
said there's nothing like a black model
on the runway yes you were surprised
that this story had not been told yes
when I was approached by the directors
and YouTube about this doco series I was
like what do you guys bring into the
table that has not been said before and
they said there's never been a
documentary about black models or Black
Beauty for that matter yeah so I
definitely came on board so that we can
tell our own stories well let me tell
you something I've watched the episodes
that they put up so far I learned a lot
for instance I thought it was
interesting that back in the day you had
to bring your own makeup Your Own
Foundation you'd go on calls and they
say we can't do your foundation we can't
do your hair yeah the first German yeah
yes the first job that I booked was
American Vogue literally the third day I
arrived in New York and I had never worn
makeup before for so the makeup artist
there was a Caucasian model on the set
he did have makeup and then when he
approached me he said did you bring your
own Foundation yeah because he didn't
have anything for me how'd that make you
feel uh it felt for me at that time I
didn't know because I was so young and
new in the industry but it felt like
something was amiss something was wrong
yeah and then I definitely did create my
own Cosmetics because I really wanted to
create to have you know in fashion image
is my currency yes so how I look in
magazines how I look in pictures it's
really truly what they want and so I
wanted to have some control over that
and may I say images your currency and
your image your currency is pretty good
it's still pretty good you they also I
learned a lot too about models back then
saying there could only be one so if you
go on a call and you see another black
woman you can see lots of other white
models who are showing up but if there
was a black woman they'd say well I
probably don't have a shot that's how it
was only one exactly and exactly so they
were creating tokenism they create the
idea that you have dethroned the other
black model so you can have some space
so what immediately I did I was majoring
in political science so I come from that
mentality that as a group as a tribe
we're more powerful than singularly so I
teamed up with Beverly Johnson and we
became best friends and so so we took we
got rid of that token is immediately
yeah say that again about you were
majoring in political science because
there's that common story somebody just
said this to me yesterday well you know
she was discovered when she was herding
goats I know people still believe that
Iman I know I know and I came when I
came here I was not only majoring in
political science but I spoke five
languages thank you very much for five
languages and one out of five I'm
serious oh first Somali Arabic Italian
French and Swahili yeah I speak English
and piglet but I mean that was a story
that was put out and so that's sort of
been disputed but I'm amazed at how many
people still remember that I have to
talk to talk to you about your beloved
David because it's been six years since
we've lost him yes and I'm wondering how
you're doing how you're feeling you know
when it first happened we were all in
shock about it but you went to your
place and the Catskills to sort of
recover and heal yes right yeah yeah
well absolutely you know memories are
the Everlasting things we have of when
you know my mom has passed away three
days three months after David passed
away my father passed away last year so
you know but you hold on to those
memories and those memories sustain you
through the years and let's not forget
I'm a mother of three a grandmother of
three you're a grandmother and a
grandmother of three what's your grandma
named Nana Nana okay and you're the
mother of two daughters and you just put
something on Instagram the other day of
you and of Lexi and David singing back
in the day can we please show that it
really I was so warm when I saw this oh
look at this
right oh
[Music]
wow
that you let us in that way yes what how
is Lexi doing and what do you miss most
about David uh everything you know we've
been together for 26 28 years so you
know but you all had a strong strong you
guys had a strong sense of self when you
got together that's that was the uh the
blessing in disguise that I didn't meet
him when I was in my 20s you know but
he's been through with me with all the
stuff that has been happening in the
fashion industry and that how I have
really wanted instead of calling out
people yes or designers I wanted to call
them in so that they can understand what
was going on was you know he's always
watching and the documentary is knockout
I'm so glad you participated because
they said Iman was a Zenith you were the
Zenith you're still the Xena thank you
Iman thank you look fantastic
grandmother of three first two episodes
of supreme models are streaming now on
YouTube Originals with weekly episodes
of we'll be right back